my name is Edie Snowden I used to work
for the government
for the public technology is the
greatest equalizer in human history it
allows us to try on new faces join new
communities engage in new conversations
and discover who we are and what we want
to become our generation is facing a
time where governments around the world
are questioning whether or not
individuals can be trusted with the
power of technology if we can be left to
our own devices and use it creatively
rather than destructively
and while I don't know the answer to
that question what I do know is that
governments shouldn't be the ones to
decide we should and what I did was not
to benefit myself I didn't ask for money
I gave this information back to public
hands and the reason that I did that was
not to gain a label but to give you back
a choice about the country you want to
live in
you